- [Voiceover] "Dina
purchased 200 feet of fencing
"to make a rectangular
play area for her dogs.
"The possible area, A, is
given by the equation below
"where W is the width of the play area."
So they do the work for
us, where they tell us
what area as a function
of W is going to be.
"Which of the following
equivalent expressions
"displays, as a constant or coefficient,
"the value of the width for which
"the area is a maximum?"
So that's an interesting
way that they phrased it,
but they're saying that
these are all equivalent
expressions to this thing up here,
and you could verify that
they're equivalent expressions.
We could take, for
example, this first one,
right over here.
This would be the same thing as negative,
let's see, W minus 50
squared is W squared,
minus two times 50
times W so minus 100 W
plus 2,500.
And then you have plus 2,500 out here.
Now this is going to be the same thing as
negative W squared,
plus, I'm just distributing
the negative sign,
plus 100 W minus 2,500,
plus 2,500,
which these two things
cancel each other out
and you're left with this
expression right over here.
Negative W squared, negative W squared
plus a hundred W.
And this would be true for all of these.
So these are all just
algebraic manipulations
of this original thing.
Now, what they're asking us,
or one way to think about it is,
which of these show the maximum value?
Which of these forms of the expression
make it easy for us to find
what the maximum value's going to be?
Well let's look at this first one.
This first one, let's
think about how this,
this expression works.
If this part right over
here, W minus 50 squared,
that's always going to be non-negative.
'Cause if you take the
square of something,
it's going to be non-negative,
but then if you then
take the negative of it,
it's going to be non-positive.
It's going to be non-positive.
So this part over here is going to be
less than or equal to zero,
and then you have plus 2,500.
So if you wanted to
maximize this expression,
which is the same thing as
maximizing this expression,
because they're equivalent,
you want this thing, you want
to not subtract anything.
So you want this part to be equal to zero.
So how can this part be equal to zero?
Well the thing that you're
squaring is equal to zero,
and in order for the thing you're squaring
to be equal to zero, W minus 50
needs to be equal to zero.
Or W needs to be equal to 50.
So just looking at this expression,
we're able to figure out,
'cause all of these expressions
are equivalent, and they're equivalent
to this expression right over here.
Just looking at this expression,
we're able to figure out, look,
this expression takes on a maximum value
when W is equal to 50.
And to their question,
"Which of the following
"equivalent expressions displays,
"as a constant or coefficient,
"the value of the width for which the area
"is a maximum?"
We know that the value of the width
for which the area is a maximum is 50,
and this one, I guess displays it.
I've never seen a question
phrased exactly like that,
but it does display the number,
and this is why this form is so valuable.
You want to say, "Look, this is going,
"the area's gonna have
a maximum value when
"this part right over here
is not taking anything away
"from the 2,500."
In fact, 2,500 is going
to be that maximum area.
And when do we reach it?
When this thing is zero,
this thing is zero,
when W minus 50 is equal to zero,
or when W is equal to 50.
So I would definitely pick this one here.
These other forms of these expressions,
and you can algebraically expand these.
It'll come out to be the
same thing as over here.
These don't help you so much.
You can't make that same type of,
that same type of intuition about
where the maximum value is.
And this form of a quadratic,
this is called Vertex Form.
It makes it very easy to find the vertex,
which is going to be the minimum
or the maximum value of
an expression, or of a
function, I should say.
Now there's other ways
to come up with the 50.
You could say, "Look, this
thing right over here,
"you have a, it's a quadratic."
It's got a negative coefficient
on the quadratic term,
Or on the second-degree term,
so it's going to be a
downward-opening parabola,
so it might look something like this,
where if this the A axis,
the area axis,
and this right over
here is the width axis,
that's the width axis,
you would know that this is
gonna be downward-opening,
because it has this
negative right over here.
It's gonna be a downward-opening parabola,
so it's gonna look like this.
And so we just need to find the vertex,
or we need to find the W,
the W coordinate of the vertex, there.
And there's a couple of
ways that you can find
the W coordinate of the vertex.
One, you could say that that coordiate
is going to be halfway
in between the W values
that make our function equal to zero,
and so we could say, "Well
what makes this thing
equal to zero?"
You could say, "100 W minus W squared
"is equal to zero."
You could factor out a W.
So W times 100 minus W is equal to zero.
Well this is going to be equal to zero
when either W is equal to zero,
or 100 minus W is equal to zero.
So or, W is equal to,
W is equal to a hundred.
If W is equal to a hundred,
this part over here
is going to be equal to zero.
The whole area is going
to be equal to zero.
So this right over here is 100,
this one over here is zero.
The maximum point then, the vertex,
is going to be the W that's
halfway in between these two,
which is going to be 50.
So that's another way to think about it.
You could also use the
formula for the X-coordinate
of a vertex and negative B over two A.
If you had an expression in the form of
A, W squared plus B,
W plus C, then,
and then we could say A,
A is equal to, this is a lower-case here,
then the vertex is going to be the
W-coordinate, I should say, of the vertex
is gonna be negative B over two A.
And in this case, in this case,
B is 100, is the coefficient
on the first degree term,
so it's going to, if B is a hundred,
negative B is negative a hundred,
and A is this negative one
that's in front of the W squared.
It's the coefficient on
the second degree term.
This, they wrote it the other way around,
where they have the first degree term,
and then the second degree,
here you have the second degree,
then the first degree.
But A is negative one,
two times A is negative two,
and then negative divided
by a negative is a positive.
Hundred divided by two is 50.
So any way you look at it,
W equals 50 is when it
hits the maximum value,
and if you looked at these expressions,
which of these involve 50
as a constant or coefficient?
Well, I see a 50 right there.
It's a little bit of a
strange way of asking it,
but there is a 50 there.
It's being subtracted,
but it does show up.
None of these other ones have a 50
anywhere to be seen.